so this is a picture of dr karotkov
dr krotkov is a very famous russian
doctor
lived about a hundred years ago and
something he came up with something very
clever still affects all of us or most
of us today so he lived
in the early 1900s and around 1905 he
started thinking he was thinking about
blood vessels and he was trying to
figure out how to use his stethoscope
let's draw the skin here over the blood
vessel how to use the stethoscope to
listen and figure out the blood pressure
so he was thinking
how can i get about to do that so
first thing he decided to do was
inflate a cuff
like a blood pressure cuff and it would
put a lot of pressure on the outside of
the skin
on that blood vessel so he thought well
let's for example let's do something
like 200 millimeters of mercury
and
for this example let's just assume that
he's working with me let's assume that
he's working with my blood vessel
and my blood pressure is about 115
systolic over 75 diastolic
so if you put 200 millimeters of
pressure on the outside what's going to
happen the first thing is that that
vessel is definitely not going to stay
open right it's going to collapse down
so it's going to do this
as
it gets all that pressure and the blood
is going to turn right around and say
well we can't go through this way
so if he listens with this stethoscope
here if he's listening he would really
hear silence he or he he would hear
nothing at all it'd be very quiet so let
me put
silence
because there's no blood flowing at this
point because the vessels collapsed
okay so dr krodkov thought about this
and said okay well what if what if i go
ahead and
do something slightly different let's
let's open this up a little bit
because what he's going to do next is
instead of putting
200 millimeters of pressure
as he did the first time he's going to
put exactly 115
exactly the
systolic pressure in my blood vessels
and he's still going to listen with his
stethoscope so here's the stethoscope as
before he's going to listen
and now
the pressure on the inside of the blood
vessel actually does reach 115 for just
a moment right so it gets there for just
a moment and a little spurt of blood
gets through
so i'll say a little pulse or spurt of
blood makes it through
and here's the interesting bit
as that blood is going through
because that vessel just barely opens up
it actually has to squeeze its way
through and it creates a lot of
turbulence meaning that that blood is
not flowing smoothly it's actually
bouncing off of the walls creating lots
of movement
and that actually translates into sound
waves because all the little air
molecules get shaken up
and you can actually hear that so when
you hear that pulse
when you get a pulse you actually hear
some sound so for the first time you
actually get a little bit of noise
so i'll put that down to noise
and the reason for this noise is that
you have turbulent flow
which is actually really really
important and it's interesting that he
observed that or figure that out
so when you go from silence
s to noise n
dr krotkov realized that that's the
moment when you've actually figured out
someone's systolic blood pressure
really kind of a neat way to deduce this
right
systolic blood pressure and so then he
said okay what if i take it one step
further what if i
relax that
pressure on the outside even more so
instead of 115 now let's say the
pressure is
i'm going to say
75
75 millimeters of mercury and he's of
course using a stethoscope to listen
he's still listening
and he realizes that now blood is
actually going to flow really smoothly
very smooth flow through this vessel
and we actually call that laminar flow
so now you get laminar flow
laminar flow
as opposed to the turbulent flow you had
before
and
now that you have laminar flow you don't
have all that bouncing off of the walls
that i was talking about earlier
and so because of that it's actually
quite
quite quiet it's very silent again so
again you go back to silence
but for a very different reason the
first time there was no blood flowing
that was when there was 200 millimeters
of mercury but now there's 75
millimeters of mercury which is a lot
less and you still get silence but for a
different reason now there is blood
flowing but it's flowing so smoothly
called laminar flow that you really
don't hear anything with your
stethoscope and he realized that
now when you go from a noisy situation
back to a silent situation
now you've figured out someone's
diastolic blood pressure
so every single time we go to the you
know physician's office or
see the nurse practitioner to get our
blood pressure taken
we we owe it to dr kroetkoff in his
observations about a hundred years ago